comenzamos este vídeo con 5 números y la
idea es ordenar los de menor a mayor
puede que sea obvio para ti que estos
cinco números son números negativos
entonces concentrémonos en cuál de estos
números es el mayor tal vez te sentirás
tentado a decir ah bueno si sabes que
todos estos fueran positivos 40 sería el
mayor así que podrías pensar que 40
negativo es el mayor pero lo que debes
estar pensando es lo siguiente puedes
pensarlo como si fueran dólares en la
cuenta de un banco que preferirías 40
negativo en tu cuenta del banco o 7
negativo en tu cuenta 40 negativo
significa que le debes 40 al banco es 40
- que tener nada 7 negativos significa
que tan sólo le debes al banco o 7
dólares entonces en este caso menos 40
es menor que menos 7 y el que está más
lejos entre estos números es el menor de
todos entonces menos 40 es el menor y lo
puedes ver como la cantidad de dinero
del banco es decir es lo menor que puede
haber en tu banco no solo no tener
dinero si no deberle al banco 40 dólares
luego el número más pequeño que le sigue
sería menos 30
-30 y el que le sigue sería menos 25
menos 25 el que le sigue sería menos 10
menos 10 y finalmente el mayor de todos
los números y vamos a escribir esto con
un color rosa eso el mayor de todos
ellos es el número menos 7 si aún no te
resulta obvio puedes pensar esto también
como en temperatura cuál de estas
temperaturas sería más fría ya sea que
hables en celsius o en grados fahrenheit
menos 40 sería la temperatura más fría y
menos 7 sería la más caliente habría más
calor en el aire a una temperatura de
menos 7 otra forma de verlo es dibujando
una línea de números y de este lado
dibujamos una línea de números y
colocamos aquí el cero y para fijar
ideas vamos a poner el número más 7 + 7
no es uno de esos números
y podemos ubicar entonces al menos 7
ahora a su izquierda tendremos a menos
10 nota como cada vez vamos más lejos a
la izquierda del 0 y luego nos vamos un
poco más lejos a la izquierda y llegamos
a menos 25 todavía un poco más lejos y
llegamos a menos 30 y si todavía vas más
lejos llegamos al menos 40 si piensas de
esta manera el menor de estos números es
el que esté más lejos a la izquierda del
0 y el mayor es el que esté más a la
derecha